may i ask a quick question what has your
role with john and tristan been as far
as how much have you allowed john so far
to step in you say you need to give him
maybe permission
have you encouraged him to step in what
is the status of
your guys's communication as far as you
and john about
what the expectations are um i don't
think that it's been clear
like we talked about and um you know i'm
i think i've been very controlling about
my own situation this is my household
this is my child
but at the same time i can kind of give
mixed messages when i'm in a state of
desperation which happens
with um you know teenagers i mean i
spend a lot of my days
in tears because i'm frustrated and i
have this partner over here
and i want his help but yet i feel like
he's like well i don't know how to help
you because you haven't
told me what my role is so um
jacqueline i got to tell you right now
if you could take a moment with me and i
need you to say to yourself
um i forgive myself because i'm hearing
a lot of
um of what i've done wrong and how i've
caused confusion
but you have to understand you're just
doing the best you can i've been a
single parent
i know how hard it is when you're
dealing with your own emotions the
emotion of your child you're trying to
maintain a household
you got to release that right now you
did nothing
wrong and i need you to say right now to
yourself i forgive myself
for the things that i think that i did
wrong because i
actually was doing what i thought was
best can you say that for me
i forgive myself for the things i did
wrong
because i thought that i was doing my
best or i was doing my best
good job that's such an important three
right now
that's hard to say jacqueline i'm going
to say to you i'm so excited and happy
that you took that first step and i saw
you getting emotional
when you said i forgive myself because
it's something you're going to need to
remind yourself
daily but i want to ask you secondly
what is your biggest fear
that you think is gonna happen if when
this
the family comes together um there's
probably two
one is that i will
my son or my partner will feel neglected
but mostly my son
you know john can handle himself he's an
adult so
i'm worried about hurt feelings on both
sides
um and i'm worried that because i came
from such a
crazy childhood
and wanted that picket fence so badly
and then you know kind of crashed and
burned in that last relationship
so it's like i feel like the stakes are
so high you right now
are hooked in to fear that's what you're
hooked into
you're afraid that someone's going to be
neglected
you're afraid that you're not going to
be able to create the life
that you have dreamed of that you know
that you deserve that your
your son deserves that you know that you
and john deserve together
you're hooked into fear and you gotta
let go of that hook
so that you can hook into what's really
important right now
so the first thing can you say i'm gonna
i'm gonna let go of this fear
i'm gonna let go of this fear it's
that's a thing that you're gonna have to
remind yourself and i see you getting
emotional
but the reason that it's important for
you to let go of that
fear it's because what you need to now
hook into
which is so important hook into all the
positives hook into you know what
i've been through this i know what to do
my son loves me
you know what i can give john permission
because i trust him
i can do all the things that i didn't
know how to do before
because i can hook into what is right
and what is love based
can i ask you a question jacqueline yeah
are you afraid that you just simply will
not survive
another dose of what you got 10 years
ago
yes it
destroyed me and i feel like i spent
so much time rebuilding myself and
learning how to finally be
independent and create this little home
that is not much but it's ours and
so yeah i'm scared
i'm really really scared what does
tristan feel about this
how is his relationship with john what
is his expectation of this situation
so that's a great question um i wouldn't
even
consider this if tristan and john
weren't already great so they're great
i was really worried that i would never
be able to
want somebody in my home and so john and
i kind of joke
yeah john and i have joked about it for
years like when we finally buy a house
it's going to be a duplex and you're
going to live on one side and i'm going
to live on the other and
there might be something too much it's
the perfect marriage
um but then something shifted and it
became
right and so now here we are and the
issue is my fear
when the fear starts saying oh no this
is not gonna work say you know what
my son loves john this is gonna work
thank you wow well i i feel sorry about
that if i would allow myself to be
excited i'm excited
thank you jacqueline and thank you
[Music]
you